trutv's hidden camera prank show
Impractical Jokers has been delighting
fans of hidden-camera comedy since 2011
whether you're a longtime aficionado or
brand new to the show here are a few
Joker's related tidbits you're probably
unaware of class clowns making goofing
off with your best buds from high school
into your job sounds like a ridiculous
pipe dream but that's exactly what
happened to Brian Quinn Sal Vulcano
James Murray and Joe Gatto
the longtime friends were born within
nine months of each other on Staten
Island and met their teens at an
all-boys Catholic High School the
perfect proving ground for fine-tuning
their prankster jobs Murray says that
high school shenanigans helps shape
their specialized skill set making them
well practiced in the art of pranking
one such early prank gadot's frequent
attempts to touch people with his nose
without them noticing even made its way
on to Joker's who says school doesn't
prepare you for the real world oh I feel
like we're about the cause of
international incident
[Music]
troopers goofing off is fun and all but
you need to find an audience if you're
going to make a living at it so in 1999
the ghost Wonga comedy troupe called the
tenderloins fast-forward to 2007 when
the four friends enters the Carson Daly
curated NBC on my comedy video
competition it's your show their entry
time thugs an infomercial spoof about
some time hopping goons that can fix
your past helped nab them the top prize
of $100,000 Jimmy Jenkins what no I
first want to know you little bastard
the guys took the cash and put together
a pilot for Spike TV in 2008 called
mission uncomfortable that would
ultimately become Impractical Jokers the
network ultimately decided not to pick
the show up but the guys often show
snippets from it at their live shows
jokes on them the idea for the pilot
came one
when the guys were discussing prank
shows and were inspired to invert the
formula and make an upside-down
hidden-camera show where they were the
butt of their own jokes or one of their
butts is the joke the tenderloins say
they don't consider Impractical Jokers a
reality show or even necessarily a prank
show but instead just a platform for
their comedy for dudes wreaking havoc in
public sure sounds like jackass but the
guys are quick to point out that the
joke is always on them instead of the
unsuspecting public or as Joe calls them
merely the instrument of embarrassed
behind the schemes when Joker's started
out it was literally just four guys in
control of every aspect of the show they
even shot that pitch episode for truTV
in 2010 with their iPhones after the
success of the first two seasons they
finally started making enough money to
hire some writers to work with them in
creating the jokes and brainstorming
ideas for challenges low-risk high-yield
investments little risk flutter yield
you don't want to put too much risk out
there and you bring a lot of yield in
it's all about the yield right but that
doesn't mean the foursome a hands-off
after six seasons and Counting Murr
describes the show as an improv show in
disguise with about 60 to 70% of it's
made up on the fly Joe still oversees
all the editing to ensuring the
Tenderloin stamp remains firmly on the
Joker's product no matter how big they
get of screen antics
the guys may be getting paid to force
each other into the most excruciating
situations imaginable on TV but that
doesn't mean they lay off in private
they play tricks on each other
constantly off camera and much like on
the show Murr is typically the target
one of their favorite pranks involves
increasing the tip Murr leaves at
restaurants by adding a digit somewhere
on the receipt while he's distracted
where is cruise credit Rodney
there's money on the fold you use us to
buy everything you guys wanna drink yeah
in common the guys rarely dead Joe to do
anything in public anymore
so convinced the day that he'll do
pretty much anything proposed to him
just to laugh after all this is the guy
who walked down Wall Street in a wedding
dress with his bill gussied up as a
groom beside it how does the dress look
joke is in the wild far from one prank
ponies the guys have shared their
comedic talents elsewhere with Sal and
Murr doing an episode of Bones in 2015
and all four Joker's are scheduled to
make an appearance in the Syfy series 12
90s Q is set to star in a new movie
directed by indie horror maestro Adam
Green which means he's likely to get his
head blown off in some wonderfully
gruesome way but Murr says their solo
interests won't keep them from their
Joker's duties and the guys will keep
working together for a long time to come
guys stop hey watch your language but
it's a family-friendly show season six
is coming and I'm going to destroy the
three of you thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all these
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]